why are you so determined to embarrass
me I'm about to tell him to embarrass
you I'm determined to be taller than you
are the cast of the Harry Potter
franchise were all perfectly behaved
behind the scenes I'm an angel I'm an
angel okay maybe not but they did share
some sweet moments on set as well as
some potentially Dangerous Ones if
you've ever wondered how slugs taste or
how Ginny coped with being trapped in
the Chamber of Secrets we'll fill you in
are you into embarrass me Ginny waited
so long for Harry to finally return her
affections but Bonnie Wright wanted to
wait even longer before locking lips
with Daniel Radcliffe apparently they
both felt it was strange to smooch
someone they'd grown up with which made
each actor nervous needless to say they
didn't quite get this in one take it
took quite a few the first did you know
Bonnie estimates that their nerves cause
them to redo this scene 30 times before
Harry and Ginny's first kiss looked
convincing in the Half-Blood Prince the
lesson Bonnie learned from this when it
comes to kissing or just filming a kiss
sometimes you just have to go for it we
had fun doing it it was we joked about
you know speaking of awkward onset
kisses tons of fans were excited to see
Hermione and Ron lock lips for the first
time or at least we're willing to put up
with it in exchange for never having to
hear lavender say again but behind the
scenes Rupert Grint and Emma Watson were
both dreading it since they considered
themselves siblings at that point
believe me we both want it to be over
equally as much as the other as clever
as Hermione Emma came up with a plan she
knows that rather than doing 27 takes
she knew if she committed really early
we'd get it she wasn't about to do 30
takes like Bonnie and Daniel so she
threw herself at Rupert right away once
we did it it was it was it was nice we
know Daniel Radcliffe can act but can he
dance you might not know what to believe
after seeing this clip of him and
shefali chaudry at the u-ball in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire we learned
even witches and wizards have school
dances full of drama apparently it took
a little time for Harry and pravati to
get their moves right on set it is just
later Daniel claimed to be a fantastic
dancer but because Harry's not very good
I felt is he a really bad dancer or a
really good actor Ron's Brothers Fred
and George are notorious troublemakers
but Rupert was the real problem on set
sometimes Stars couldn't help but giggle
during a scene and every cast member in
the Harry Potter franchise is guilty of
this but no one caused as many
disruptions as Rupert you shouldn't be
laughing at the end when you find out
the Dan's gonna potentially be killed by
slave his laughter distracted his
co-stars I can see Rupert laughing in
the mirror I could say I can hear him
Snicker in my ear frustrated the crew we
will start giggling and he'll pretend he
isn't giggling and ended up causing the
need for a penalty system for
unsanctioned laughter
Bonnie was forced to pay up during the
Half-Blood Prince during the scene in
which Ginny brings Harry a mince pie
because she just couldn't stop giggling
in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
first year Hogwarts students learn how
to fly brooms for the first time playing
hand games might not be quite as
exciting as soaring through the sky on
Brew but it made for some adorable
behind the scenes moments apparently
Emma couldn't help but take Play Time
seriously and her cast members noticed a
competitive streak right away
Emma slapping hands with Tom Felton was
so cute we can't believe she was
smacking him in the face just a few
years after this annoying nose
it's not worth it but don't let Emma
Watson fool you she's a competitive and
clever person but that doesn't mean she
can't be bad once in a while this star
has broken character due to laughter
quite a few times and was seen using her
cell phone while on set on the bed with
her shoes on everyone knows Electronics
don't work at Hogwarts Emma as much as
we love the movies they can't
incorporate every element from the books
even if we don't like to admit it one of
the things cut from the films was
Hermione's oversized front teeth but it
turns out Emma did have some at least
for a while
according to Sorcerer's Stone director
Chris Columbus Emma is actually wearing
false teeth during this scene but he
realized she couldn't keep acting with
them in her mouth oh are you doing magic
let's see them what's more difficult
than trying to get a big group of kids
to cooperate on set how about trying to
keep them in line when they're flying
through the air that was a real problem
thanks to all those quidditch matches
and when we saw dueling in Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets maybe that's
why Harry usually sticks to a simple
disarming spell expelli armor
as you might have guessed based on this
scene we talked about earlier there was
no love lost between Hermione and Draco
not unless we're talking about Germany
fan fiction but behind the scenes Emma
admits she had a huge crush on Tom
Felton when they were kids that's right
during the first two films Hermione was
really smitten with Draco the entire
time some people think Emma and Tom are
dating in real life but he claims that
when he found out about her Crush I
Heard it Through the Grapevine and then
eventually you know we became we became
good friends poor Emma had to film her
scene on the Hogwarts Express with fake
teeth while Rupert and Daniel got to
stuff their mouths with candy
well hopefully not every flavor George
swear to get a bogey flavored one months
apparently nobody ever told Daniel not
to play with his food
Daniel Radcliffe and Rupert Grint are
friends in real life but on set they had
a few differences apparently Rupert was
a little bit shy and didn't want to be
seen while he was getting his hair and
makeup done will there not be seen like
this yeah meanwhile Daniel had no
problem wearing some different clothes
during Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows wow we're identical Ron learned
about the dangers of a broken wand the
hard way when he ended up cursing
himself with a slug vomiting charm in
chamber of secrets we know Ron didn't
have a lot of fun being cursed but
Rupert didn't exactly enjoy it either
for Rupert this movie moment was the
most challenging part of the franchise
at that point he had to put slimy
plastic slugs in his mouth and then well
you know don't worry there was at least
one upside to filming this scene but it
tasted quite nice actually in order to
make the process a little bit easier the
crew made sure to add flavoring to the
Slime so Rupert was tasting chocolate
fruit and peppermint apparently Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets was
full of challenges for the cast and
Bonnie Wright struggled to get through
one of the scenes Ginny Weasley has a
bigger part in the second movie but
unfortunately that was because she was
being tormented by you know who she
ended up in the Chamber of Secrets
laying on a very cold marble floor
according to Bonnie the floor was so
freezing that she couldn't handle laying
on it for long enough to film the scene
so in order to get her through it the
crew hid hot water bottles in her
clothes to keep her warm as poor Jenny
grows weaker Emma Watson has had tons of
success both within the Harry Potter
franchise and outside of it but there
was a time when filming Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Part 2 she actually
missed her Mark literally escaping
Gringotts wasn't easy behind the scenes
either but at least there wasn't a real
dragon
behind the scenes bloopers are one thing
but Helena Bonham Carter did some real
damage to one of her co-stars while
working on Harry Potter and the Order of
the Phoenix Bellatrix Lestrange has a
real mean streak while Helena's harm was
entirely accidental during one scene
Bellatrix gets her hands on Neville
Longbottom and puts him in Peril in
front of his friends it turns out actor
Matthew Lewis was in real danger of her
wand Matthew moved while Helena was
poking her wand at his ear and the two
collided ouch Matthew ended up with a
perforated eardrum and didn't come clean
about what happened for three days don't
worry the pain and hearing loss was
temporary although the jokes kept on
going Helena says she would always shout
to ask Matthew if he was all right after
this don't give it to her
which one of these behind the scenes
moments was your favorite do you think
the cast was perfect together or would
you have preferred some other stars
instead
who's ready for a set tour the Harry
Potter films are filled with magical
sets we all secretly wish we live on but
what was building and acting on these
sets actually like
as much as we all wish Hogwarts was real
the truth is only a miniature version of
it was created for exterior shots while
that's impressive in itself there are
still locations you'll recognize in the
UK that they used for the filming of
Harry Potter Durham Cathedral Annika
Castle new College laycock Abbey and
Gloucester Cathedral all hold a tiny bit
of Hogwarts with them kind of like a
jigsaw puzzle the Philosopher's Stone
was the only film that they shot in an
actual location for the Forbidden Forest
after that it was all up to the set
designers to recapture the magic that
came along with it this was because of
aragog's Lair the most challenging part
getting the roots right the roots became
the most interesting sculptural part of
it and The Roots got bigger and bigger
not only did they hand sculpt the trees
and Roots but aragog as well by the end
of the films they had created 600 foot
long backdrops of the Forbidden Forest
and trees that were 12 feet in diameter
watching Hogwarts crumble wasn't easy on
anyone especially the set designers the
entire process of creating and destroyed
Hogwarts for the big battle took three
months and is where the majority of the
cast said their goodbyes while they
relied heavily on green screen for the
backdrops of the battle all the rubble
Rock and explosives we see were added in
when building the set I think sometimes
when something is destroyed it shows the
scale of it they also had the extensive
challenge of making the rubble soft yet
realistic this was because there were
constantly actors running full speed
through the rubble and they didn't want
anyone getting hurt the majority of the
walls and structures were made out of
plywood so they could be realistically
destroyed
Diagon Alley was probably one of the
more versatile sets the franchise had it
changed for every film depending on what
shops and storefronts were needed for
the storyline however no matter what the
set designers had the challenge of
Designing sets that were slanted crooked
and overall very unique the inspiration
for this set was the stories of Charles
Dickens there was one scene where they
shot on location for Diagon Alley in the
Philosopher's Stone when Harry visits
the Leaky cauldron that scene was
actually filmed at leadenhall Market
believe it or not the Diagon Alley set
was also used for hogsmead told you it
was versatile because both towns had the
same Wizardry and magical feel they
would switch storefronts add in some
snow and anything else that was needed
and they'd have the small town just
outside of Hogwarts that we see Harry
and his friends exploring in the
Prisoner of Azkaban the first time we
see Gringotts in the Philosopher's Stone
the cast actually filmed at the
Australia house in London but jumped
forward a decade to the Deathly Hallows
and the set designers actually
reconstructed the entire set this was
because the flying dragon scene would
have been impossible to film otherwise
if you pay attention you'll see that
while it's almost an exact replica the
designers just couldn't find the same
exact marble floor or wood paneling
Louise libero is one of the warmest sets
of the entire film which meant they had
to pay extra attention to all the family
details throughout the films we've seen
many different variations of the burrow
and while they created the interior of
the home for the Chamber of Secrets how
could we forget the infamous magical
clock and self-washing dishes they
constructed both a new interior and
exterior for the Half-Blood Prince the
ministry of magic set we see in the
Order of the Phoenix took a whole three
months to build it was important for the
set designers and director to get this
right because it was another extension
of The Wizarding World that Harry had
never seen before I've never used a
visitor's entrance before it should be
fun
the set was so detailed that it included
actual fireplaces where the Wizards
traveled using flu powder a daily profit
stand bankers and carts full of
parchment being pushed around by some of
the 300 extras the room of requirement
was probably one of the most difficult
sets to film in that the crew designed
while the novel describes the room full
of cushions and books they wanted to go
a more neutral route in the film Stuart
idea was to put the mirrors all around
the room and and very quickly we
realized you know that no way to avoid
Reflections because the room was
surrounded with mirrors they also needed
to figure out the lighting situation
which resulted in many meetings and a
discussion to just go the CGI route in
order to get rid of them as for the cast
this set wasn't the most Pleasant either
stifling stifling Heat James Phelps had
admitted that he hates the room of
requirement set turns out being in a
room full of Hogwarts students
practicing magic isn't the most ideal
situation after all in fact Bonnie
Wright called it suffocating
the Great Hall is some of the first
magic the characters and the audience
get introduced to the set was built in a
studio but was modeled after the real
life Christ Church College along with
the hall set designers also crafted
Dumbledore's lectern and the Hogwarts
house point counter an item that was
said to have been the cause for a
national shortage of Indian glass beads
if you need any more proof the Great
Hall is its own kind of Magic the
reaction we see of the first years
walking in during Philosopher's Stone is
their raw reaction that was the first
time they had stepped onto that set
whenever we have a new cast member come
in they always talk about when they
walked into the Great Hall set because
it's just it's amazing the Great Hall
was used for the six following films and
was even transformed for the eule ball
in the Goblet of Fire a set actor
Warwick Davis loved mostly because he
got the okay to crowd surf during
filming we see Dumbledore's office a few
times throughout the film which means
they constructed it completely in the
studio to use in each film they made
sure that they stuck very close to the
books for this set even including the 48
portraits of the Headmasters bookshelves
that had books mentioned in the novels
The Sword of Gryffindor his memory
cabinet and finally the pen sieve this
even doubles as the room where Lupine
and Harry studied magic together in the
Prisoner of Azkaban they just switched
out the props this Hogwarts washroom set
from the Half-Blood Prince may not have
been memorable to us but for Tom Felton
it's one of his favorite scenes he's
ever shot this was because of how
practical they made the set for the
effect we see on screen when we did
spells normally not a lot actually
happened but in this case they rigged
the whole bathroom up with explosives so
every time you gave a little flick
something would blow up which was very
satisfying when Harry makes his way into
the Chamber of Secrets in the second
film what we see there was entirely
constructed in studio however in the
last film they recreated that set using
VFX and green screen
excuse me sir can you tell me where I
might find platform nine and three
quarters I think you're being funny do
ya Harry Potter wouldn't be Harry Potter
without platform nine and three quarters
there's just something about running
through a brick wall that gets you every
time while the majority of these shots
were done in the real world at King's
cross Station in London for the final
film they recreated the platform the
train and the tracks for interior shots
they transformed an old steam engine
into the Hogwarts Express and would film
it moving along tracks for exterior
shots we all know how huge the Harry
Potter franchise is around the globe but
it is still shocking that they were able
to get permission to close down London's
Piccadilly Circus for this Deathly
Hallows scene that's basically the Times
Square of London in Deathly Hallows part
1 shortly after the golden Trio leave
Fleur and Bill's wedding they find
themselves in Piccadilly Square
surrounded by hundreds if not thousands
of others in order to get this scene
shot they had to block off certain parts
of the road and gathered crowds of
extras to cooperate with their filming
but still ran into other challenges we
were surrounded by Paparazzi which is
also not great because of the flashing
of their cameras you'd think working on
one of the biggest movie franchises of
all time would make actors nothing but
smiles yet some of the biggest names in
the Harry Potter series actually had
parts of the job they hated let's take
the train back back to Hogwarts and find
out more Mr Potter himself Daniel
Radcliffe was not only first on the call
sheet but also first on the list of
actors who struggled with the movies but
to be honest when you think about some
of Daniel's reasons they make sense for
starters there were some specific scenes
he struggled with like in the Goblet of
Fire he has to pretend to fall from the
top of the castle while being chased by
a dragon now before you start shouting
at the screen I'm aware both the castle
and the dragon were CGI but they still
had to put Radcliffe on a wire and drop
him like really fast to make it look
real because it was very very physical
and what is real is that it scared the
Living Daylights out of him and speaking
of uncomfortable scenes he also didn't
particularly enjoy all the Quidditch
scenes not because of the heights but
because they'd strap him to a broomstick
for hours and hours and as you can
imagine the broomstick was in a fairly
sensitive area of his body we'll just
leave it there Radcliffe also had issues
with the process as a whole he and the
other child actors had basically zero
acting experience going in so they were
learning how to act while doing it in
front of an entire set for a cast and
crew and on camera for the world to see
it was arguably the most anticipated
series of all time too that's a lot of
pressure for an actor regardless of age
so he avoids watching the movies unless
he has to I see them at the at the
premiere and then if I can I avoid ever
watching yes because when Daniel does
look back at the early movies especially
he gets really frustrated at his
performances he's on record saying that
when he watches them he sees himself
making acting mistakes that like
everyone makes at the beginning of their
career but unlike everyone else he
didn't get to make them in an acting
class or a rehearsal room instead
they're permanently out there for the
world to see I think it would just be
it's you know it's like passing around
baby photos of yourself it's not an
enjoyable experience but his issues with
his acting go further than that even as
far as the sixth movie the Half Blood
Prince he doesn't like his performance
he's called it one note and accuses
himself of being complacent about the
process though I should note he had nice
things to say about what he did in the
Order of the Phoenix so that's something
but unfortunately the issues for Daniel
extended to more than just cringing at
the movies the pressure of the gig
actually led to him developing a
drinking problem he's talked about
having an addictive personality and the
scrutiny and pressures of being the one
and only Harry Potter definitely made
that side of him come out he was was
drinking every day and not just like
casual sips he did make sure to say he
was never drinking while he filmed the
movies unfortunately he was able to get
the problem under control and quit
drinking altogether in 2010. as we all
know Daniel wasn't the only kid actor
having to learn how to act while on
camera Emma Watson has talked about
having the same frustration as Daniel
only with an added twist early on as
Emma was filming she had a kind of
hilarious habit of mouthing along to
everyone else's lines as they said them
a stone that may skull stops you from
dying no wonder Snape's after it which
to be honest is a total Hermione Granger
move am I right
but it wasn't hilarious to Emma
this is actually quite traumatic for me
she also issues throughout the series
with her independence or rather her lack
of one she's talked about how tough it
was to basically have every minute of
all her days mapped out for her minute
by minute and how she didn't have any
control over it so she was told when
she'd be picked up and brought to the
stat went to eat and when there was
enough time between shots for her to use
the restroom it got under her skin so
much she seriously considered leaving
the series halfway through the strain of
Fame was another factor and hers was
maybe even worse than Daniel Radcliffe's
in the sense that she had to deal with a
literal stalker a dude showed up at her
school one day trying to find her and
from then on she had to hire private
bodyguards to protect her like Radcliffe
Emma also had particular movies and
scenes she hated shooting for starters
she talked about how the shoot for
Deathly Hallows part 1 involved a ton of
outdoor shots that took forever it was a
grueling process that was just a little
too intense for Emma but she even had
issues with some indoor scenes too like
when she had to wear a dress and enter
the ballroom to dance with Victor Crump
she got so like flummoxed with all the
direct that the director was shouting at
her she ended up falling down the stairs
oof and maybe the hardest shot for her
was inside the Chamber of Secrets in
Deathly Hallows Part 2 not because of
anything physically rigorous but because
she had to kiss Rupert Grint AKA Ron
Weasley the two are close friends and
have been basically growing up together
on set so to her it felt like kissing a
sibling hey you know what feels like the
opposite of kissing a sibling
subscribing to the channel just saying
anyway Emma wasn't alone in that
particular feeling Rupert talked about
how strange it was to kiss his friend
and that they were both super
self-conscious as they slowly leaned in
he said he was relieved when it only
took him four takes to get the shot and
like Daniel Radcliffe Rupert also had
his issues with the Quidditch scenes for
the same uncomfortable reasons you guys
I think it's safe to say that nobody
likes to have trouble sitting after
spending hours with a broomstick wedged
between their legs plus Rod had the
added fun of being smacked one time in
the face by a quaffle I always assumed
those were done with CGI but apparently
they're real so now I'm questioning
every everything but that's my own
burden don't worry about me Rupert also
has Arachnophobia AKA fear of spiders so
it was not super fun for him to film the
scene where he has to face a giant
spider aragog because even though the
final product had a CG spider they still
tried some takes with an animatronic one
too I had a film panic attack and we
never did it again Rupert's also talked
about the fact that Not only was he
never trying to act as a career but he's
also a total introvert so that's
probably not a great combo when you
become one of the most famous child
actors in the world he had a really hard
time adjusting to his total lack of
anonymity even going so far as to say
it's like having a split personality
like he's almost had to create a
different personality in his mind for
when he's out and getting bombarded by
fans and people taking photos yikes he
even talked about quitting acting after
the series ended not necessarily because
he didn't enjoy it but because he felt
like he'd missed out on having a normal
childhood so he was just looking to be a
real person out in the world for a while
and I'm sure the fact that he had
already made several lifetimes worth of
money from the movies made the idea of
quitting a little less scary besides our
main Trio there were some other actors
who took issue with elements of being in
the Potter movies but he was still super
heartthrobby as Cedric Diggory sadly
Cedric dies at the hands of Voldemort
and this scene was pretty uncomfortable
for Mr Twilight to film to make his body
contort in the right way for the death
to look real they had to wrap a wire
around his um groin region and then they
propelled him backwards it was quite
unpleasant on his little diggeries he
also said it was really hard filming all
the underwater scenes Dame Maggie Smith
didn't have any underwater scenes but
she still found the whole process
unpleasant and not for reasons you might
expect Smith AKA Professor Minerva
McGonagall is a legend of acting
particularly in Britain her issues have
less to do with the Harry Potter series
itself and more about movies and TV as
mediums she's such a fanatic for stage
acting that she finds movie and TV roles
to be pretty unsatisfying and that
includes both the Potter series series
and her incredible role in Downton Abbey
she also didn't really care for the
heavy weight of the hats they had her
wear in Harry Potter but that seems
pretty reasonable please don't make
older folks wear unnecessarily heavy
clothing people the costuming wasn't too
much of a burden on the late great Alan
Rickman but he had other issues he of
course played Professor Severus Snape
and despite absolutely nailing the role
and endearing himself to a younger
generation of fans who don't know about
the amazingness of Hans Gruber he wasn't
super happy with his part after Rickman
died some of his letters were sold at an
auction and in them there were some
disparaging things he had written about
the Journey of Snape over the course of
the movies he apparently felt like one
of the directors David Yates was
abandoning some of the potential
character Arc for Snape in an effort to
Simply appeal to teens of course since
that's exactly who the movie was
marketed to it's hard to fault Yates for
that finally we have John Cleese one of
the most revered comic actors of all
time and a member of the legendary Monty
Python sketch group while on Graham
Norton's talk show he was seated next to
Taylor Swift Harry Potter who mentioned
what a big fan she was of the Potter
movies place's reaction was pretty
dismaying to Taylor basically slamming
the movies it was awful and I can see
his point really the movies are like 90
CGI so I can imagine that actors who
have been at it for years acting
opposite a green screen or a mop with a
head on it might be pretty boring
the battle at the department of
mysteries feels just as intense behind
the scenes as with the incredible CGI in
the Final Cut weather was enhancing
Flames during the battle of the Weasleys
or adding magical effects to the Battle
of Hogwarts the Harry Potter team did it
all because we are the high-tech
multi-million dollar production that we
are um the snake's double was a pole
with a boxing glove toy to the end in
the Goblet of Fire we get one of the
most intense battles as Harry and
Voldemort face off at the end of the
tri-wizard tournament but behind the
scenes the battle looked pretty
different of course lights and effects
were added to show the casting of spells
in their duel but editing also had to be
done on Ray finds his face to give him
the snake-like appearance of Voldemort
Harry's parents make their appearance as
well but while filming Radcliffe didn't
actually have their support behind him
the two actors filmed their parts at a
different time and in a completely
different space after the fact the
editors managed to tie it all together
flawlessly
this emotional battle was just as
intense while filming as the completed
fight in the Final Cut we can totally
believe they were dodging spells and
trying to claim a victory without seeing
the lights of spells being cast the
tension in the room especially as
Bellatrix takes serious out is very
evident I kept on doing like Ping Pong
sounds
during the Battle of Hogwarts Voldemort
and Harry make their way throughout the
castle battling in any room they can
find this epic staircase duel was no
different while behind the scenes they
were really on rubble-covered steps the
rest of the scene looked much less
violent and magical without the CGI
their acting energy was high and the
Harry Potter and voldemore actors waved
their arms dueling for their lives in
the end as the two go head to head for
the last time we see an emotional but
much calmer scene than in the movie and
of course Ray finds doesn't dissolve
into the air after his defeat the battle
in the astronomy Tower is quiet and
still without the CGI the mood on the
set while filming was quite similar
behind the scenes looks just as dark as
we feel seeing the Final Cut of this
heartbreaking moment and the loss of
Dumbledore with the smallest spell from
Snape yes
the major battle of Hogwarts in the
final film was just as chaotic behind
the scenes instead of CGI people huge
crowds of actors were on the set amid
the rubble while camera people ran
backwards through them capturing all the
action The Dumbledore and Potter Duo
facing off with Voldemort is filled with
fire on screen but without the special
effects it looks like a bit of a
different story of course we couldn't
get a real fiery nagini or construct the
entire Ministry set so CGI filled in all
the details
Hogwarts was in a seriously desperate
stay while under attack from the fiery
quidditch Stadium to the countless
spells being cast none of which we see
in the unedited footage
CGI was key to amplify the gruesome
scene as more enemies stormed the castle
Neville's fall was also made a reality
thanks to some excellent editing of the
shots captured on set
that went well what could be better than
one Potter the seven Potters battling
and racing away to get Harry in
themselves into the Wizarding World
safely involved a ton of CGI especially
when it came to the Speedy motorcycle
chase with Hagrid
CGI was important to amplify all the
flames and environment for the wicked
battle at the Weasleys but surprisingly
behind the scenes was nearly as
flame-filled the space did have actual
hay surrounding them alongside a few
fires to perform with but the vast field
was in fact a blue screen on set but
there's one condition
obey every command I give you without
question Dumbledore facing the cave
infested within fairy is dark and
terrifying and behind the scenes on a
partially constructed set Michael gambin
brought the intensity acting pretty well
on his own the film crew included real
fires and moving lights to help create
the right effects
underwater filming was extremely intense
even without all the added effects
to help depict Radcliffe's struggle a
rope was tied around him to pull him and
give the right sensation thank goodness
for the CGI used to erase the rope from
the image afterwards of course the
horcrux itself was edited into the shot
as well
what brings you here Potter
I could ask you the same onset filming
the battle in the room of requirement
the actors were surrounded by real
Flames climbing practical sets and on
occasion sporting safety harnesses to
pull off all the magic behind the scenes
we don't see the fire snake whipping
through the piles of furniture either
but the performers definitely make us
believe it's there while a large space
was built to film the scene much of the
room of requirement is actually
completely CGI from the pillars to the
floors
[Music]
facing off with the Hungarian horn tail
was no small feat and Radcliffe brought
it with his performance in the first
task of the Triwizard Tournament the CGI
dragons movements were based on that of
a hawk this and the animation of the
creature were digitally rendered and
added to the final image luckily onset
there were no real Dementors but it did
mean Daniel Radcliffe had to be hooked
up to a rig that could maneuver and lift
him while the actor pretended to be
choked when editing time came around the
intricate work began and the digitally
rendered Dementors took their place
foreign
last visit to the Chamber of Secrets to
destroy a horcrux but for this very wet
scene a strategically set up green
screen acted as the base for when Ron
and Hermione use the power of a basilisk
Fang a combination of CGI waves bursting
up around them and the real wave of
water soaking the actors made for an
epic scene we saw Maggie Smith come to
life as she exerted the most graceful
power facing off with and making a fool
of Snape in the midst of the war at
Hogwarts CGI was responsible for the
effects of the Spells but Smith was
responsible for the fierce power
what tree this is Hermione and Harry vs
the Whomping Willow wouldn't have been
possible without the added special
effects that brought the tree to life
and made it a force to be reckoned with
when the scene got a bit more intense
Watson wound up swinging around on a
prop Branch while Radcliffe tried to
avoid being hit by what would eventually
be the tree's trunk the actual set the
burning of Hagrid's home was filled on
wasn't too different from what we see in
the final film aside from some effects
to augment the dark and gloomy scene the
fact that there's an actual explosion
taking place on set adds a major wow
factor to this heartbreaking scene as
Bellatrix celebrates all the Havoc she's
caused
bread I've been thinking exactly the
same thing Fred and George really stick
it to Umbridge with a literally
explosive exit from Hogwarts wreaking
complete Havoc throughout the dining
hall the twins filmed they're flying
separately on a broom in a green screen
setting enabling the editors to add
their images to the chaos of the dining
hall we know by now it's not just people
or animals that can be dangerous plants
can be fierce in the World of Harry
Potter and the Maze didn't go easy on
Cedric Diggory instead of vines wrapped
around him Robert Pattinson was tied up
in a rope and pulled to mimic the way
the Ferocious plant drags and traps him
for a moment there I thought
you were gonna let it get me
that's the moment so did I I have a
terrible facial hair problem while the
professors in Harry Potter may have a
wand up there you know what the actors
themselves love pulling pranks and
laughing on set I remember and it was
called the one broomstick
number one disrespecting Professor
Umbridge is something we can get behind
while we can't tell you why this deleted
scene of Professor trelawny exists we
are just so glad that it does the theory
is they were just doing a long pan shot
of all the professors and Emma Thompson
was improvising and being so ridiculous
they paused and focused on her
that ought to be
seriously we could just sit here and
watch this for another minute or two
maybe an hour or how about the entirety
of Harry Potter told through Professor
trelawny's eyes thank you Professor
Umbridge but it really was most
illuminated number two the internet will
never let Daniel Radcliffe forget this
one Michael gambin and Alan Rickman
pulled the best prank on Dan we're ain't
really funny and for you while he's
supposed to be silently sleeping in a
room full of other young Wizards the
Mayhem began in our dreams we enter
completely our own world
the best part was Dan has us to have his
sleeping bag next to this particular
girl that he finds it it was Alan
Rickman who planted the fart machine and
we'd like to we like to swim in the
deepest Waters but it was Michael who
was pressing the button
Michael and Alan were good buddies on
set Michael was always making Alan laugh
and they were lucky if they got a take
where he didn't crack so you are CE
number three we would take Maggie Smith
that's our dance partner any day of the
week this leg moves fast Maggie in
character teaching Rupert Grint to dance
while she's hanging out in her robe is
just hilarious put your hand on my your
right hand on my waist it's probably
good we've got visuals to describe the
scene otherwise you might have thought
something else no you will have to lead
eventually her metaphors are the perfect
cocktail of Elegance and quirkiness
inside every boy a lordly lion prepared
to prance and Rupert Grint was just a
wee bit embarrassed of the whole
situation telling onlookers that no one
is to breathe a word about the moment
Never Gonna Let them forget this are you
never number four Magic meets technology
Alan Rickman whacked his hand off the
camera and only had this anticlimactic
thing to say
and yet it's still hilarious he's not
one to Break character too much unless
Michael gambin's around but odds are
this footage wasn't salvageable anyways
number five a thousand takes would make
for a long day Robbie coltrane's
responses to literally everything are
just hilarious
1000 take one
was that a thousand what hey Robbie
we're not sure a thousand takes is
necessarily a good thing we do our best
to do it number six if only Ron were as
talented with a wand as he is with a
quill Rupert Grint was caught doodling a
nasty image of Alan Rickman Alan Rickman
was standing right behind me and I was
so scared life imitates art sometimes if
you're playing the quote unquote Evil
dark arts teacher you should just expect
some sassy students the picture wasn't
nice either it was uh yeah I think I
exaggerated a few of his features well
Alan Rickman like the true gentleman he
is kept Rupert's art I've made him sign
it and I have it in my possession
and I'm very fond of it number seven now
for the hero of Our Generation when
filter's cat is petrified in the movie
Kenneth branagh's character said ah
thought so so unlucky I wasn't yeah I
know exactly the counter curse that
could have spared her but we found
another improvised take it was
definitely a curse that killed her
probably the transmogriffian torture
encountered it myself once
number eight or Richard was too gentle
for this world Richard Harris thought
the animatronic of fox the Phoenix was
real and so when no one else was in the
room he was interacting with the bird
and the sneaky tech people were
puppeting said animatronic from outside
of the room to let him believe in the
magic nobody ever told him the bird was
fake and we think it's just better that
way pretty good huh number nine children
are a nuisance while Professor
McGonagall would never threaten to hurt
a student we never use Transfiguration
as a punishment Maggie Smith might not
be so strict with herself like how about
this moment she pretends she's going to
thump one of the kids with a scroll yes
yes we know it's all teasing number 10.
Robbie Coltrane goofing about in the
motorcycle makes everyone on set burst
out into Giggles including Dan
this lovable goof can probably make even
the grumpiest of people laugh on a bad
day number 11. our least favorite
Professor is full of Personality while
Professor Umbridge is evil in the movie
Behind the Scenes Imelda Staunton and
McGonagall were best buds Imelda sings
Oh yes
and she blah blah blahs about blah blah
blah blah disloyalty oh number 12 we
still find it hard to believe Hogwarts
hosts a rave did you know Professor
Flitwick crowd surfing at the Yule Ball
was only meant to be a joke it's true I
said wouldn't it be funny if Flitwick
did a stage dive the director went away
for the weekend and Warwick Davis
couldn't believe his ears he said we're
gonna do that and I said I was only
joking here's hoping he enjoyed himself
and maybe ticked something off the
bucket list number 13 never let go filch
David Bradley wasn't meant to hang on to
Tom Felton forever but he just wasn't
ready to let go even while the cameras
weren't rolling but hey maybe he had a
perfect grip and just didn't want to
lose it number 14. what is it with Harry
Potter and gas he was a little boy
obviously in the first one and he said
he was really traumatized by her Miriam
Margolis hasn't bothered to watch most
of the Harry Potter movies well I've
only been to the one ones I mean and I
fall asleep if you remember Professor
Sprout with the screaming plants she's
not happy about her time on Harry Potter
or rather not happy if she wasn't in all
of them that was a great oversighted I'm
holding you responsible Miriam
traumatized Daniel Radcliffe when he was
a wee boy she's quite the character
which you'd know if you've ever seen her
on a talk show ages but a number and
she's hilarious I've been told there was
a sweater involved on set well a young
Dan didn't appreciate her behavior with
the cursing I was probably careful when
it was you but when you know with the
other kids I did involved but that
wasn't the worst part though it was the
farting that really got to him I'm very
proud of it number 15 it doesn't take
Michael gambin a transformation spell to
alter his performance Michael's a bit of
a goofball when we do the scene now
again in a minute I should change my
this cracks up Radcliffe in a completely
different way Michael we applaud your
Nuance the cast of Harry Potter still
leaves us laughing even all these years
later do you ever wish you could go back
in time and experience it again for the
first time filming a World of Magic can
be seriously tough in our world from
almost drowning to facing their worst
fears to some very nasty injuries the
Harry Potter actors injury a whole lot
of struggle so let's check out which
scenes were some of the most difficult
to film over the years
was the most horrifying thing either of
us but before we dive in you should
probably subscribe to our new channel
the things animated to get all the
hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows number one
well torture is never really supposed to
be fun so I couldn't stop crying even
when you're acting opposite someone as
incredible as hell in a Bonham Carter
being tortured in a scene is a real
challenge Watson shared that it was
quite horrible to do the actress reacted
so intensely that she actually made the
Bellatrix actress and director David
Yates feel uncomfortable
number two
word of advice pass on any challenges
that involve being underwater everyone
knew filming this part of the tri-wizard
tournament would be a challenge Dan
Radcliffe did some solid training time
in the pool with professional divers to
prepare for filming but he was
definitely no expert meaning at times he
forgot what hand signals meant what
communication underwater has to be done
physically so when the dive team saw the
actor giving the help me signal they
freaked out worrying that Dan was
drowning this this confused me luckily
the actor wasn't in danger meaning to
signal to everyone that he was actually
A-Okay however by the end of it all
Ratcliffe had spent 41 hours under very
cold water he was lucky the worst he
wound up with was just two ear
infections
frustrating
number three
the room of requirement couldn't be
everything for everyone all the time
unfortunately for Bonnie Wright this
room full of magic and power was really
tough to work in because of how
claustrophobic she was left feeling with
Dumbledore's Army being so big there was
always a crowd and being confined into
such a small space left right really
struggling her on screen Brothers
weren't such big fans of the room either
the Phelps twins struggled with how much
heat the fireplaces throughout the room
emitted making for some seriously sweaty
actors and all those warm sweaters
foreign
number four
her character definitely wouldn't have
felt this way Imelda Stanton really is a
great actress we'd never have believed
that she actually felt awful when
torturing Radcliffe the always evil
character was the furthest thing away
from who Staunton was and the actress
admitted that filming those scenes was a
real struggle for her calling it
horrible and unpleasant horse Staunton
was left feeling guilty for days after
the fact whenever she had to go full
evil you know the scene where she gives
him the detention was uncomfortable for
me
number five
this was a doozy Cedric losing his life
is very sad but it looks fairly simple
technically the truth is though
Pattinson suffered during filming
because of the stunt he had to do for it
the actor was set up with some wires
wrapped around his groin area that would
allow him to roll once hit with the
unforgivable curse let's just say our
Pats was very happy when the Final Cut
was called
number six even his co-stars were
shocked he took on a stunt this big
Radcliffe had proven he could take on
some stunts himself and perform to the
caliber needed safely so by the time the
Goblet of Fire came around he wanted to
amp it up signing on to perform the big
slide down the roof of Hogwarts for the
cameras sure he wasn't really on the
roof of a castle but the set that was
created did leave him with a 40-foot
jump on wires and it still looks pretty
terrifying I will never be allowed to do
something like that again number seven
when there are seven Harrys things get
tricky we'd think that the fact that
Radcliffe was the only one actually
acting out the scene when he played the
rest of his crew disguised as himself
would make things easier but it was
straight up tough and kind of endless it
took a whopping 95 takes to capture all
the action properly since Radcliffe had
to act out the scene over and over again
playing each different part it was time
consuming but oh so worth it in the end
number eight Emma wasn't shy about how
much she detested this experience yes I
can tell you the worst right now it was
on movie number two we get dropped by a
dragon into the lake and Rupert wasn't
so crazy about it either considering he
thought his heart stopped beating from
the cold it was the middle of winter and
the water they were in wasn't heated and
they couldn't wear any extra layers
since they had to change out of their
wet clothes so quickly after out of the
trio Watson was the only one to have the
help of thermal pants
number nine oh this part always makes us
cry sirius's untimely end remains one of
the top worst losses in the whole
franchise in part because of Radcliffe's
heart-wrenching performance this was the
scream so blood curdling and guttural
that the team couldn't even include it
in the film it had Helena bottom Carter
and Emma Watson in bits so we can only
imagine how brutal it was for Dan in the
moment especially since he lost such a
close family member around the same time
number 10.
it sounds like a party but Emma Watson
wasn't a fan let's face it kissing
someone who's like a brother is tough
doing it twice well that's just not fair
to make it all worse when Emma and Dan
Radcliffe got together to smooch the two
of them really got stripped down and
neither one was expecting it Watson
shared that it was the weirdest thing
ever and they only told us about the
silver body paint the day before Watson
has been nothing but honest about the
experience explaining that it was
awkward enough as it was without the
silver paint and the strapless bra but
whatever it looks good for the story as
for kissing Rupert the actress was fully
clothed but it was still tremendously
tough to get through especially because
the two had such a hard time staying in
character and then expressed her
frustration saying it was supposed to be
that dramatic kiss but Rupert and I
continued to laugh I was really worried
that we'd never get to get that scene
because we just couldn't take it
seriously number 11 animals are cute
until you work with them if any of the
actors were fans of monkeys or bats
before they definitely weren't after
filming with them the monkeys couldn't
keep calm and were harder to Wrangle
than the young kids and some got a bit
explicit on set and Grint had a terrible
time when filming with the bats since
one of them decided to do its business
on him yeah that ain't cute
number 12. the spider is huge Rupert
Grint was Ron Weasley in almost every
way including the fact that they both
suffered pretty serious Arachnophobia
the Chamber of Secrets was
unquestionably the actor's nightmare
aragog was portrayed by a giant creepy
animatronic puppet that looked real
enough to leave Grinch shaking in his
boots he even called them the scariest
scenes to film even when they weren't
filming the presence of aragog on set
just gave Rupert the creeps number 13.
it definitely worked in this case
Professor Snape love them or hate him
Alan Rickman gave a stellar performance
and that was partially thanks to method
acting the after kept in character
whenever he was filming on set so the
first scene he filmed with the kids
wound up being a real challenge for them
while Rickman definitely didn't mean to
he intimidated some of the young actors
so much that they really struggled to
focus we'd be nervous too luckily that
quickly went away once they spent some
time together off camera and they saw
that smile we all love
number 14 fans of the books remember him
the character didn't make it into the
movie but Rick Mayall had actually been
on set and gave a very memorable
performance
so why have we never seen it well the
actor did such a wonderful job that he
caused the young actors to giggle
endlessly and remember this was for the
very first movie so these kids giggling
too long could lead to Serious delays in
production they tried filming with the
actors back to the kids and with him
across the room but he was just too
hilarious every time director
Christopher Columbus wound up not liking
the look in the end so he just cut the
character harsh
number 15. it's fun but complicated the
high-flying sport never existed before
it was written into Harry Potter so JK
went on to create a full detailed rule
book so the production team could make
sense of what it was how to play and
then film it in a way that would
Captivate audiences after all no one
wants to be watching these kids flying
around on broomsticks if we have no idea
why Harry was so obsessed with finding
that golden flying ball aka the snitch
their production designer Stuart Craig
was the one who took on the daunting
task of creating what the pitch would
look like and his design worked like a
charm in the later films quidditch
became some of the most brutal scenes to
film since those broomsticks were not
comfortable at all even with the
modifications made to try and give the
actors an actual seat to sit on oh and
we can't forget Rupert Grint also got a
quaffle to the face at one point that's
gotta hurt
number 16. they loved it so much they
filmed it twice okay well that wasn't
the reason the production team was
forced to reshoot the entire epilogue
scene because the first time around
everything was way too rushed and
chaotic especially for such an important
moment all the actors felt really
Bittersweet seeing each other looking
aged and knowing this would be the final
scene of the franchise well we get
teary-eyed just thinking about it
number 17. who left the food out for a
team that was usually thinking about
everything it's pretty surprising that
no one would have realized what would
happen to the real food they filmed with
for days on days under super hot lights
the foul smelling set made filming a
total drag for everyone who was close
enough to smell the stench and by the
time they got rid of it that smell was
seeping out of the Great Hall the actors
may have been chowing down on real food
for the first day but no one was taking
any more bites once their plates were
filled with rotten food a nasty sight
for them a tasty one for us
number 18 Dan says it best
we were very much just like kids being
kids on a set filming the early movies
especially the very first one was an
absolute dream for the child actors but
for the adults involved well it could be
a bit of a nightmare since filming
anything with a big group was extremely
difficult with children who were
distracted by the magic of it all and
each other big problem was like
throughout a take our attention would
like would Wane and come and go but it
was pretty sweet to see how much the
little ones enjoyed it or they were just
so happy to be in a Harry Potter film
that they couldn't contain their
excitement they laughed they cried they
got some serious injuries and had some
very emotional days but they made some
pretty special memories and of course
Very Special movies in the process
dragons
first ask The Wizarding World can be a
dangerous place so which of the Harry
Potter actors struggled through the most
pain whether it was because of sets or
other cast members these actors were
left bleeding bruised and battered all
in the name of art so let's see just how
much damage they endured
I'll be freezing number one it just
hurts so good poor Dan Radcliffe
struggled through the most painful first
day on set that he could have imagined
that first day we were trying to get
Dan's eyes to be green because that's
what they are in the book Sporting Green
contact lenses that gave him a wildly
painful allergic reaction this was so
brutal that he couldn't even bear to
wear them another day
green ice since which explains why we
never really got those famous Lily
Potter green eyes you're heavy on my
mother's eyes here yeah absolutely and
unequivocally no number two this queen
took him down Rupert Grint didn't know
what hit him I'll be a knight
during the giant chess game the moment
Ron was struck by the queen wound up
being way more painful than anyone
intended Grint got nicked in the face by
a rogue Rock and was left bleeding the
evidence of what happened even made the
Final Cut
don't forget we're still playing number
three like son like Father after seeing
this deleted scene we can without a
doubt see why Draco is the way he is for
Tom his on-screen father could be
intimidating with Jason was not
always a treat just immediately turned
into the most unfriendly horrible person
and Tom even had the cuts to prove it
Jason Isaacs came into filming his first
scene with all the Malfoy cruelty in
check smacking Tom's hand on set not
realizing just how much damage those
fangs on the end of his stick could do
Tom was left bleeding and with tears in
his eyes but it's good for the scene
number four snow can do some serious
damage the Final Cut of Prisoner of
Azkaban even shows us how Felton was
feeling about those snowballs when he
visibly flinched before even getting
smacked who is that a snowball fight can
be fun for one day but going at it over
and over and over again well that snow
can hurt bloody hell Harry that was not
funny number five rule number one don't
mess with Hermione such a good moment
one of the all-time greatest moments in
the HP series is no doubt when Hermione
delivers a knuckle sandwich for the ages
and while they did it fairly safely on
set the prep to do so wasn't so smooth a
film earlier Tom wanted to practice so
they could get comfortable with it but
what he didn't realize is that Emma
would have no problem at all delivering
a vicious slap across his cheek quite
frankly he's been asking for it Emma has
admitted looking back on it that she had
no idea what she was thinking never
again did Tom offer himself to that kind
of torture The Sting of that slap stayed
with him that felt good no good
brilliant
number six the struggle was real Harry
did spend a fair amount of time of the
Goblet of Fire film underwater so the
fact that he wrapped up a whopping 40
hours in the water tank is not
surprising and because of that we can
understand why he also wound up with two
ear infections during the filming
process the pain really never stopped
with this one number seven it wasn't
just the actors who suffered on this set
director mcnewal really liked to get
into the action and wanted to make sure
he could get the best performances out
of his actors when it came time for the
Weasley twins to fight Newell wanted to
see even more fire instead of the prissy
work he described he was seeing but this
director learned his lesson saying of
course I was a tubby 60 year old gent at
that stage and I really shouldn't have
done it and why is that well because
when he got into it this director wound
up breaking two of his ribs while
demonstrating how to fight he wasn't
feeling like such a tough guy after that
one you know when you shouldn't break a
director's rib
[Music]
the tournament was tough from the start
while Dan wound up in pretty rough shape
afterwards he'd did get to perform one
of the coolest stunts he'd ever done a
major 40-foot slide down the roof
understandably he was terrified and his
body was feeling it after the fact Dan
shared with the experience was like
saying I was on a wire but I was
properly in free fall it was only there
to catch me at the end number nine not
the kind you're thinking though Matthew
Lewis struggled through the early years
forced to look like nerdy Neville around
all the kids growing up why is it always
me and then he endured some seriously
painful torture after Helena Bonham
Carter accidentally stabbed him in the
ear with her wand now this left Lewis in
agonizing pain nursing a perforated
eardrum he could hide his pain well
since no one actually knew until after
the fact when he confessed that he was
indeed suffering internal bleeding
number 10. good friends know when it's
time to put a friend in their place
Hermione was ready to call Harry out if
he ever crossed a line and this one well
he paid the price for
yeah that's not what she was wanting to
hear from Dan that said her brutal
reaction left the actor with a sore face
afterwards you're laughing because you
hit me so hard don't you okay
what can we say Hermione is a
firecracker you don't want to mess with
number 11 this can't end well and
surprise surprise it didn't as if
Radcliffe hadn't faced enough hardships
on these sets filmings left him with a
brutal cut on his lip this wasn't just
any snake he was facing off with the
snake Radcliff was going tattoo with was
the stunt coordinator on the film who
was wielding a pole with a boxing glove
stuck on the end of it and in one take
they got a bit too feisty Radcliffe
shared that it went up and smacked me in
the mouth and my teeth went really hard
into my gum so I had a fat lip for about
a day number 12 you gotta do what you
gotta do and Hermione was ready to get
to work even if Harry was hesitant but
she needed that hair to make the poly
juice potion yikes though Watson
definitely did not mean to hurt Dan in
the process only to help him but as
we've seen sometimes Hermione just knows
what's best I am so very much in touch
with everyone that I worked with number
13. Emma could also cause herself some
pain growing up on set meant Watson
could feel comfortable to experiment and
try pushing herself in ways that one may
normally not be able to and to be fair
she did go a bit too far with this one
acting like you're being tortured
doesn't really sound like an appealing
day on set but it was particularly bad
for Watson who kind of lost herself in
it and caused some serious pain to her
psyche the physical aspect was rough too
and all that torture action left her
body feeling really sore and exhausted
by the end but she did give the
performance of a lifetime number 14.
that's not quite the way you want to
leave a set but unfortunately for Dan
bruises took over his body the final
film of the franchise had stunts that
Dan described as the greatest physical
challenges he'd faced off with vicious
creatures but it was scaling up
chaotically piled Furniture in the room
of requirement while trying to find
ravenclaw's diadem that really threw him
the fact that he's spent a full seven
hours doing it meant he was black and
blue all over by the end of the day I
was just bruised and battered number 15
it was the Battle of a lifetime
finishes the way we started
and considering how it turned out well
it was a win for Harry but Dan paid the
painful price Ray fines didn't hold back
and Dan could feel it he explained I
wore padding but he missed it a couple
of times so anyone who doesn't like me
can come to the movie and see me getting
beaten up to be fair did we really think
Voldemort would go down without a fight
but we did about three or four takes and
it was a really intense moment so what
we can conclude is that being part of
the Harry Potter franchise was a serious
Hazard even if you weren't acting in it
as director Mike Newell unfortunately
found out which situation sounds most
painful to you